nous sommes avec Pierre et Maryse cette
affaire elle est folle ils sont obligés
de dormir dans un camping-car alors
qu'ils ont une maison à eux qu'ils ont
payé et leurs locataires refusent de
partir elle ne paye plus le loyer elle
ne paye plus l'eau aujourd'hui vous êtes
étranglés financièrement vous dormez
dans un camping-car vous êtes retraités
il y a l'hiver qui arrive
vous êtes malade vous avez des des des
des pathologies très très compliquées et
graves aujourd'hui la lettre sachez-le
si vous nous rejoignez elle est et
l'ordonnance est sur le bureau du préfet
c'est dur c'est dur parce que
j'ai plus d'espoir parce que je vois que
c'est tout le temps pareil l'avocat nous
dit vous l'aurez pas vous voyez très
long pour nous pour se remettre de tout
ça si on s'en remet un jour ça va pas
très évident ça va pas être évident mais
passer deux confinement là deux ans et
demi là croyez-moi